MORE DAMAGE IS DONE TO BOTH THE
AND THAT'S THE ANKLE.
FORMER NATIONAL SPOKESPERSON FOR
THE FBI AND HERE IN WASHINGTON
IS JOE, A FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY
FOR WASHINGTON, D.C.
JOE, YOUR REACTION TO THE
BROKE ON ALL THE OTHER CHANNELS
AND ON NBC, CBS, IT WAS TRUMP TO
BLAME?
>> TO BLAME IS McCABE AND TO
BLAME IS COMEY AND ANYBODY ELSE
AT THE SENIOR LEVELS OF THE FBI.
THIS IS QUITE A DISGRACE FOR THE
THIS IS QUITE A DISGRACE FOR THT
FOR THE BUREAU.
AS SOMEONE WHO WORKED WITH THE
BUREAU, I'M TRULY SADDENED BY
THE FALL FROM GRACE FOR
EVERYBODY THERE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT, THIS
WAS A PLOT TO EXONERATE
HILLARY CLINTON ILLEGALLY AND
THEN IF SHE LOST THE ELECTION,
TO FRAME DONALD TRUMP WITH A
LEGAL CRIME.
THIS WAS THE WORST PERIOD IN THE
PERIOD WHEN THEY WERE SPYING ON
DOMESTIC GROUPS.
THIS IS THE WEAPONIZATION OF THE
FBI FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES BY
ALL THE PEOPLE AT THE UPPER
ECHELON OF THE BUREAU.
I THINK IT'S REALLY TIME FOR
FOR THE SENIOR PEOPLE AT THE
WAKE UP AND SEE THAT WHAT'S
COMING NOW IS THE FEDERAL GRAND
JURY AND IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
PRETTY.
>> Laura: YOU REPRESENTED THE
BUREAU IN THE PUBLIC DOMAIN AND
YOU ARE THE SPOKESPERSON FOR THE
BUREAU.
YOUR REACTION TO TODAY'S
RETIREMENT OF THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR?
>> THEY'D BEEN TALKING FOR SOME
TIME THAT HE WAS LOOKING TO GO
ON TERMINAL LEAVE AND EXIT THE
BUREAU.
I THINK THAT WAS HASTENED AS A
WENT INTO THIS DOSSIER.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU, NO
PRESIDENT, WHETHER IT'S TRUMP,
OBAMA OR ANYONE ELSE, TELLS THE
FBI WHICH I DO.
THE FBI IS INDEPENDENT.
THEY ARE THERE FOR THE PEOPLE.
TO THINK FOR A MINUTE THAT A
SITTING PRESIDENT WOULD BE ABLE
TO PUSH OUT A DEPUTY DIRECTOR,
THAT GOES AGAINST EVERYTHING THE
>> Laura: DID YOU SPEAK TO
McCABE A FEW WEEKS AGO?
>> I HAPPEN TO BE AT
HEADQUARTERS A FEW WEEKS AGO AND
CHATTED WITH HIM BRIEFLY.
>> Laura: WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> WE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT HIM
POSSIBLY LEAVING.
AT THAT TIME HE WAS IN THE
OFFICE WHILE THE DIRECTOR WAS
OUT ON OTHER BUSINESS SO
ESSENTIALLY HE'S THE MAN IN
CHARGE.
IT SEEMED TO BE BUSINESS AS
USUAL.
HOWEVER, EVERYBODY IN THE BUREAU
KNEW THAT McCABE'S DAYS WOULD
BE RUNNING SHORT BECAUSE OF THE
HISTORY.
IF IT WAS TIME FOR THE BUREAU TO
MOVE ON WITH A CLEAN SLATE AND
GET BACK TO THE WORK THAT THE
FBI DOES.
>> Laura: JOE, HE WANTED TO
LEAVE IN THE SPRING.
THE IG REPORT IS COMING OUT IN
THE SPRING.
BUT IT'S A WILD COINCIDENCE, IF
INDEED THE FBI DIRECTOR STROLLS
UP TO CAPITOL HILL ON SUNDAY,
READS THIS VERY SHORT REPORT,
FOUR PAGES, AND THEN IT JUST SO
HAPPENS THAT MONDAY, McCABE IS
LIKE YOU KNOW SOMETHING, I WOULD
RATHER GO SKIING IN BRECKENRIDGE
FOR THE NEXT TWO WEEKS.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE DOING THIS
WORK ANY LONGER.
LATEST PUBLICATIONS, CHRISTOPHER
WRAY WAS SHOCKED ON SUNDAY WHEN
CASE, WHERE HAS HE BEEN SINCE HE
WAS SWORN IN?
THERE IS ENOUGH EVIDENCE ON THE
PUBLIC RECORD.
WITH THE INFORMATION FROM THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND FROM THE
HILL WITH THE LEGAL RELEASE OF
DOCUMENTS THAT IT WAS CLEAR THAT
MR. McCABE AND OTHERS HAD
ENGAGED IN HIGHLY IMPROPER,
PROBABLY ILLEGAL ACTIVITY IN THE
FISA COURT STUFF ALONG WITH THE
DOSSIER FROM CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
FIRST OF ALL, McCABE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN GONE A LONG TIME AGO
AND SO SHOULD STRZOK AND PAGE
AND ALL THE PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
THIS.
THIS IS A DARK MOMENT FOR THE
FBI.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LOT FOR
THEM TO RECOVER FROM THIS.
>> Laura: WE HAD JIM COMEY
HE'S TWEETING QUITE A BIT.
VERY POETIC.
HE SAT SPECIAL AGENT ANDREW
McCABE STOOD TALL OVER THE
LAST EIGHT MONTHS.
HE ALWAYS MAKES HEIGHT
REFERENCES, I WONDER WHY.
ONE SMALL PEOPLE WERE TRYING TO
TEAR DOWN AN INSTITUTION WILL
FOR THE REST OF THE FBI.
AMERICA NEEDS YOU.
JOHN, WHAT YOU MAKE OF THE COMEY
TWEETS?
ANDREW McCABE DID A LOT OF
WRONG, THAT IS THE TIME THAT IT
HAS TO BE STOPPED IMMEDIATELY.
I HAD SOME VERY GOOD AGENTS THAT
MADE AN UNFORTUNATE MISTAKE
ALONG THE WAY.
>> Laura: HE WAS THE GUY TO
WHOM PETER STRZOK REPORTED,
CORRECT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Laura: McCABE COULD HAVE,
JOE, WE'RE ALMOST OUT OF TIME,
McCABE COULD HAVE USED ONE OF
THE REGULAR FIELD OFFICE SET OF
INVESTIGATORS TO DO BOTH THE
CLINTON AND THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION.
PERFECTION ALSO COULD RUN THIS